do you 169 yeah that's the raunchy Jonas
Brothers song we didn't know we needed
let's back it up and breakdown this wild
Joe Broz moments the guys were on
Tuesdays Late Night with Seth Meyers for
a new installment of day drinking Kevin
Joe and Nick versus Seth his brother
Josh and his pal Jack McBrayer
[Music]
it's time for day drinking Oh
first up birth order theme drinks some
were tasty this is going to be the drink
called the firstborn we're gonna start
with a 30-year old
Glenfiddich some were interesting babies
will be served in a baby body babies
love chocolate milk we're gonna replace
that with some Kahlua put in a little
Rosie because that's mom's favorite just
like the young yes and some were just
plain disgusting the middle child no
one's put any thought into you for years
you're the Forgotten child right we're
putting no thought into this drink at
all we're just gonna randomly pour stuff
in here by now the guys were pretty
sufficiently buzzed so naturally it was
time to play some games they drank even
more after failing to identify other
infamous brothers these guys killed a
bunch of people Mendez brothers sorry we
were looking for men
it would be like calling you the Janome
missus they paid homage to their
incredible hair styles of the past and
drank some more with a round of
shuffleboard social everybody drinks
but the truest display of talent came at
the end when the dueling brothers faced
off during a game called
5-minute pop song it's pretty
self-explanatory and the results were
wild day drinking with Seth Meyers was a
natural fit for the Joe Broz heck Nick
is even in the booze business himself
just last year he launched his own
tequila called Villa 1 so let's talk
about the tequila how did this come
together and do we test it on the wives
is Priyanka a tequila drinker did you
have a shot off with her no she is the
Reposado is her favorite so we've got
you know the Anejo the Reposado and the
silver and she's tried it all and she
was there actually the first time we
went to our tequila farm in tequila
Mexico and was a big part of the process
and I think for us you know family is
the most important and keeping this you
know something that that our family and
friends can enjoy and the same way that
first time we went down there and had
that amazing experience and tried to
create the culture around Villa one fact
that she's here tonight and that she was
drinking the Reposado with us it's a
special thing
[Music]